come on follow me on this journey of
liposuction 360 and a professional mini
bbl
nene leakes takes fans on her plastic
surgery journey i represent the full
fine women the reality star reveals she
went under the knife after becoming an
ambassador for georgia plastic surgery
the old folks home many years from now
are going to look crazy everybody with
giant booties up in there so i said to
him i like my ass
what i would like to do though is fix
problem areas so we call it a
professional
mini bbl
and
i love it
so i'm going to take you on this journey
with me but don't get it twisted nene's
dispelling rumors about past plastic
surgeries
if you follow me on the real housewives
of atlanta many many many many years ago
i did some surgery i did my boobs and i
did my nose right
and uh you can google that job google
everything else child
and uh a lot of people for whatever
reason thinks that i've done like a lot
of stuff i get all kinds of comments and
it's really hilarious to me but dr okoro
will tell you that i have not and that
is the truth we believe yanini
the former real housewives of atlanta
star also shared this video from her
surgery day from checking in
to going under the knife
yeah i want to look fabulous fans will
have to wait to see nene's new fabulous
bod but she says she's almost ready to
show off her new snatched look
she's going to be hot
now nene hasn't always been down with
nipping and tucking when the real
housewives of atlanta debuted she was
proud of the cast for keeping it real i
think that with us we're not so plastic
surgery i think you can turn the tv and
see these other franchises everybody's
so plastic you know booze lips and you
know faces are just pulled so tight and
you know we're just regular girls we're
really keeping it real but over the
years as her fame grew nene started
singing a different tune and shared her
surgery journey on the show i really
wanted to have my nostrils taken in and
when i learned that i didn't need to
break my nose i was in did my boobs go
down diana i can't see them they're
swollen right now it was wonderful
being in hollywood is definitely
pressure to look a certain way or to
stay
looking great and i don't see anything
wrong with doing a little nip tuck here
and there i think there's something
wrong when you do all the scary nip
tucks
flash forward to 2022 and all that's
left to do is await nene's full
transformation let's keep it classy not
trashy
[Music]